this is a pretty amazing clip from uh
some podcast other than show what
podcast it is it doesn't matter this
featuring a group of black drag queens
talking about the dangers of cultural
appropriation yes these people are very
worried about appropriation listen
I just feel like there's such a long
rooted history in appropriation from
Black Culture like for instance like
when I go to the Metropolitan Museum and
I see things that they've taken from
Africa I see things that they've taken
from Nubia and then you go yes and then
you go and you look at these pillars and
then there's this white man Samuel
something something 1800 going and
saying I'm putting my ownership on
something that was never mine to begin
with and then they go yeah I discovered
it so then it gives me this ownership
like I can take it and it can be mine
and I feel like it's that entitlement
that is one thing that we really need to
discuss like there is a way I feel to
very much so appreciate somebody's
culture but so many times like Bob says
there are times where you know they cite
the source but they don't
hmm
yes these people are worried about
appropriation
this is this is like irony
overload but and what the hell is this
those little baby heads on this uh man's
dress there I think that's am I am I do
my eyes deceive me yeah that's that's
what he's wearing
let's not uh satanic at all so you've
got yeah these people it's like I can't
even say dressed as a woman because I've
never known a woman to take the severed
heads of baby dolls and fasten them to
her dress that's not something a woman
would do but they are attempting anyway
to appropriate Womanhood and at the same
time they're a warning about the dangers
of cultural appropriation
and what's what's the example they give
for cultural appropriation the first
thing he says is a museum
so taking artifacts cultural artifacts
and putting them on display in a museum
is appropriation now
isn't that
what exactly is the difference can can
these people articulate any more a
distinction between
um paying homage to a culture or uh you
know paying tribute to a culture
showing respect to a culture and
appropriating it is there even any
difference anymore in their minds of
course there isn't
I mean there was a time not that long
ago like I don't know 15 seconds ago
where uh for cultures for museums to
have Multicultural displays that was the
politically correct thing to do
it also made sense for a museum because
if you want to use it if you're going to
a museum you want to learn about world
history it's going to show you artifacts
of world history
but now you can't even do that without
being accused of appropriation
and yet these men who are
wearing Womanhood as a costume
are somehow not guilty of it themselves
that'll do it for this portion of shows
move over to members block if you're not
a member yet you can become a member and
use code wall should check out for two
months free on all annual plans hope to
see you there if not talk to you
tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign